[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir très heureux de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv 78 nous sommes le lundi
1er février voici les titres de ce
journal premier week-end sous les
nouvelles mesures sanitaires annoncé par
le gouvernement les grands centres
commerciaux ont dû fermer leurs portes
dans le même temps le ministre de
l'intérieur a annoncé lors d'un
déplacement dans les yvelines le
renforcement des contrôles liés au
couvre feu
reportage lors d'une opération des
forces de l'ordre focus sur les pge les
prêts garantis par l'état lancé par le
gouvernement pour venir en aide aux
entreprises affaiblies par la crise
économique et dans les yvelines plus de
onze mille sociétés en ont bénéficié
comment perçoivent tel ce dispositif de
dirigeants basés dans le département
sont nos invités
et puis toute cette semaine le dossier
de la rédaction portraits d'yves linois
issus de quartiers qui continuent à s'y
investir et à donner de leur temps pour
leur commune ce soit rencontre avec
ahmed bauchi car il est devenu médiateur
social à la verrière en parallèle d'une
autre activité professionnelle avant de
développer ses titres l alerte orange
concernant les inondations levée dans
les yvelines le département est
désormais a placé en vigilance jaune
suite aux précipitations du week end est
des inquiétudes en raison du niveau
élevé de la scène d'après vigicrues le
fleuve pourrait atteindre et même
dépasser les 4 mètres à chatou et à
poissy jusqu'à 5 m 61 ali mais d'ici
demain soir mardi quelques submersion de
digues sont à prévoir avec certaines
routes et voies de transport qui
pourraient être inondés par endroits
[Applaudissements]
mais je vous le disais dans les titres
les opérations de contrôle des forces de
l'ordre liées au couvre-feu vont
augmenter le ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin a dit qu'une
augmentation de 30% étaient à prévoir
dans les prochains jours lors d'un
déplacement hier dans les yvelines
samedi soir déjà les forces de l'ordre
étaient sur le pont pour ces contrôles
les détails dans ce sujet de célia gars
de son go et de mélanie poker un trafic
exceptionnel ce dimanche 31 janvier avec
presque 400 kilomètres de bouchons
relevé dans l'heure précédant le début
du couvre-feu au péage de buchelay sur
l'a13 le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin a assisté au contrôle des
forces de l'ordre pour le respect du
couvre-feu à 18 heures il a annoncé que
ces derniers allaient être intensifiée
avec une augmentation de 30% des
opérations depuis samedi 30 janvier
exemple à la gare de saint quentin en
yvelines à montigny le bretonneux ou des
contrôles ont été effectués
on n'est plus dans la pédagogie ça fait
longtemps qu'on est bien dans la dans la
verbalisation des cas qui posent
problème mais comme je le dis avec
pragmatisme éventuellement avec
souplesse avec discernement
c'est tout drôle de fonctionnaires de
police autre point de contrôle ce samedi
soir au rond point des droits de l'homme
à guyancourt
par ces temps qui sont a quand même
assez compliqué c'est tout à fait normal
de contrat les watts pour me demander
de présenter un bon d'identité ainsi que
mon emploi c'est ce que j'ai fait c'est
là dit que je pouvais continuer mon
chemin avec mon attestation et tout
s'est bien passé
65000 contrôles ont été faits sur le
territoire seulement pour la journée du
30 janvier et 6000 verbalisations ont
lieu à la suite de ces opérations de
contrôle au renforcement des contrôles
dans la lignée des dernières annonces
gouvernementales vendredi soir le
premier ministre jean castex a détaillé
une nouvelle série de mesures pour
freiner l'épidémie de coded 19 et éviter
un troisième confinement notamment la
fermeture des grands centres commerciaux
ceux de plus de 20 mille mètres carrés
qui ont dû baisser le rideau pour quatre
semaines minimum la restriction est
entrée en vigueur ce dimanche
samedi et derniers jours donc pour faire
ses courses mélanie poker a rencontré
quelques yvelinois aux abords du centre
commercial espace saint quentin c'est à
montigny le bretonneux section décision
qui vient au bon moment et que
aujourd'hui à la panne de pandémie a
frappé très fort en france donc
je pense que c'est les millions de
choses à faire effectivement faut éviter
la mort des commerces mais ça va
peut-être permettre aux petits commerces
de survivre justement parce qu'on aime
les gros centres commerciaux je
comprends pas trop parce que hier soir
j'allais faire des courses vers 18
heures on est tous entassés les uns sur
les autres c'est franchement dommage
pour les salariés des centres
commerciaux parce que je pense qu'ils en
en mars pour connaître
ça va être dramatique et on va avoir
encore des fermetures de magasins qui
vont se faire
je pense que c'est très bien qu'on ne
soit pas confiné parce que je crois que
c'est ce que les mailles de plus en plus
anxiogène j'aurais préféré qu'on
confirme pas ce que l'on va y aller au
confinement
comme je sais pas quelle va être l'étape
du confinement mais on perd du temps là
à mon avis il s'agit uniquement d'une
fermeture pour les centres commerciaux
non alimentaire et pour une surface de
plus de 20 mille mètres carrés des
nouvelles mesures dont pour freiner
cette épidémie de kobe 19 éviter un
troisième confinement c'est un scénario
qui est sur la table actuellement du
gouvernement un nouveau conseil de
défense sanitaire est prévue ce mercredi
à l'elysée
d'autant que si on regarde les derniers
chiffres du colis de 19 dans les
yvelines la tendance est à la hausse sur
une semaine
à part pour le nombre de tests positifs
toutes les données sont en augmentation
+ 13 pour le taux d'incidence le nombre
de nouveaux contaminée pour cent mille
habitants
ça repart à la hausse également dans les
hôpitaux +84 hospitalisation sur une
semaine sept patients supplémentaires
placés en réanimation depuis le début de
la crise sanitaire et 1210 personnes
sont décédées du comique 19 dans les
hôpitaux yvelinois dans l'actualité
également ce drame à maisons-laffitte un
policier de 32 ans s'est donné la mort
avec son arme de service
son corps a été retrouvé à son domicile
ce lundi le fonctionnaire travaillait
dans le 8e arrondissement de paris il
était père de deux enfants une enquête a
été ouverte pour déterminer les
circonstances et les raisons de ce
passage à l'acte est depuis le début de
l'année cinq policiers ont mis fin à
leurs jours
[Applaudissements]
nous parlons il ya un instant de la
crise sanitaire une crise sanitaire vous
le savez qui c'est mieux aussi en crise
économique parmi les aides de l'état a
lancé pour venir en aide aux secteurs
économiques le prêt garanti par l'état
il est destiné à l'ensemble des
entreprises
c'est un dispositif qui a permet
d'obtenir un prêt auprès d'une banque
qui sera donc garanti par l'état dans
les yvelines plus de onze mille sociétés
ont bénéficié de ce dispositif pour un
montant total de 2,2 milliards d'euros
alors on en parle avec deux invités un
qui est en plateau ses écrits cordina
riant bonsoir vous êtes le dirigeant du
restaurant la fontaine qui est notamment
dédiée aux spécialités de la mer et il
est basé à montigny le bretonneux il
compte sept salariés et également en
visioconférence avec noomi qu'elle croit
thorium qui qui est avec nos bons soirs
par visioconférence blanchard dirigeants
vous de la société automation 2007 une
pme de 16 salariés installée à
coignières dans le domaine de
l'industrie est également en plateau
avec nous de la rédaction tv 78 nicolas
landry et bonsoir bonsoir grégory
pouvez-vous déjà nous rappeler quelles
sont les conditions de ce prêt garanti
par l'état là vous l'avez dit gregory un
toutes les entreprises peuvent peuvent
bénéficier d'un prêt garanti par l'état
le demande auprès de leur banque
le montant peut aller jusqu'à 25 % de
leur chiffre d'affaires l'entreprise ne
rembourse rien pendant un an
et c'est au bout de cette année que le
remboursement peut commencer par exemple
les premiers remboursements dpj est
octroyée en 2001 vont commencer en mars
prochain
et dernière chose rare et d'épée jeu
sont encore disponibles jusqu'au 30 juin
mais quelles sont les entreprises qui
sont concernés justement par cette es
jeux et bien lloris se sont toutes les
entreprises qui ont été touchées par la
crise sanitaire ne pense notamment aux
entreprises fermées sur décision
administrative mais autre situation un
des pg ont été octroyés aussi par
précaution pour certaines entreprises
écoutez les explications de christophe
sanguins dont il est le directeur de
l'agencé banque populaire val de france
à montigny le bretonneux entreprise
cible du psg ont pas pour mon
utilisation dispositif il est en moyenne
de 50% de leurs capacités
la chef d'entreprise ayant à l'esprit
qu'il se devait de rembourser son
soutien on privilégie d'autres leviers
ils ont vraiment eu une attitude
responsable de précaution et ça se voit
d'ailleurs sur la sole de loi comme
banque a en revanche on a les activités
telles que les clashs à l'événementiel
où ils ont beaucoup plus utilisé ce
dispositif
il en est de même pour les entreprises
en lien avec le secteur automobile ayant
un fort impact économique dans des
départements et un ans après nicolas
quelles sont les différentes options et
pour les entreprises justement un qui
ont bénéficié de ce pays
les entreprises ont le choix d'abord
elles peuvent directement rembourser le
prêt c'est à dire qu'une entreprise sans
emprunter 100 mille euros en bourse
directement cent mille euros au bout
d'un an
d'autres choix sont possibles pour les
entreprises elle peut décider de
rembourser sur cinq ans et la dernière
décision qui a été prise dernièrement
par bercy c'est le ministère de
l'économie
c'est la possibilité aux entreprises de
commencer le remboursement de le décaler
encore d'un an
c'est notamment le cas pour les
entreprises qui sont encore en
difficulté les banques 1 commence
notamment à recevoir les retours des
entreprises ans on a un premier retour
[Musique]
on a déjà les premiers retours
actuellement en moyenne sur un portique
an sur cinq ans on ne dépassera pas les
2 75% sur les premiers retours clients
que nous avons 80 % optent pour un
amortissement sur cinq ans dont 50 %
avec leurs forces militaires 15%
l'investissement entre les 4 ans et 5 %
sur l'avancement du prêt est juste avant
de vous redonner la parole de nicolas
donc je reprécise si vous nous rejoignez
que nous avons deux invités là et en
plateau ces cliques ordinariat
dirigeants du restaurant la fontaine à
montigny le bretonneux vous avez vous
bénéficié de ce fait j'ai eu à hauteur
de 137 1000 euros est également donc en
visioconférence à michael croitoru yuki
et dirigeant de la société automation
2000 qui est basée à accra coignard et
vous donc c'est le contre exemple
puisque vous avez décidé de ne pas avoir
recours à ce psg nicolas vous avez des
questions injustement pour nos invités
justement qui cordina rien est ce que
vous comptez rembourser directement de
près au mois de mars ou au vu de la
situation par rapport à la restauration
vous souhaitez peut être différée d'un
an encore le début du remboursement
je pense qu'on va être obligé de
demander un différé supplémentaires
d'oeuvre voilà les restaurants sont
toujours pas ouvert sur 2020 on a été
fermé plus de cinq mois
il ya presque la moitié de l'année mais
en plus on a été fermé sur les mois les
plus forts c'est à dire juin novembre et
décembre ce sont les mois les plus forts
de l'année pour la restauration
donc là il est évident qu'on ne peut pas
commencer à rembourser
même si on en a la possibilité pour le
moment il serait pas prudent de se
séparer sa trésorerie est de commencer à
rembourser un prêt sur lequel on à la
facilité d'avoir un différé d'un an
supplémentaire
la réouverture partielle qui a eu lieu
pendant quelques mois n'a pas eu assez
d'impact impact sur cette période
d'ailleurs on a été on a une bonne
surprise que quand on a ouvert au mois
de juin chez nous nous avons ouvert le
21 ou 22 juin ça a démarré très fort le
public est très demandeur donc ça a bien
démarré juin/juillet même où tu étais
très bien septembre aussi et puis fin
octobre il confinement qui est arrivé
est donc là aujourd'hui non je pense que
qu'il faut pour ceux qui moquent pour ça
je vais demander une année
supplémentaire
r c'est presque officiel à ses membres
qui regarde c'est plutôt de la
précaution on dit ou pas seulement
d'accord pas seulement alors michael
croit thorium vous vous êtes dans le
secteur industriel vous avez enregistré
une baisse de 20 % de votre chiffre
d'affaires et pourtant vous n'avez pas
demandé de prêts garantis par l'état
alors pourquoi ce choix
alors je dirais que c'est la première
chose par rapport à prêts garantis par
l'état y pour garder sa trésorerie
j'estime que si la trésorerie permet
qu'on n'a pas de problème de trésorerie
on a une responsabilité sociétale ne pas
peser plus que nécessaire sur le budget
de l'état et qui crient auquel
contribuent tous et donc j'ai fait le
choix parce que la trésorerie de
l'entreprise le permettait de ne pas
faire de prêts garantis par l'état dit
d'ailleurs de reporter mais rambo mais
mes paiements de charges sociales
quand on voit la situation de krikor
dynario on voit que par précaution il
préfère repousser le début de ce
remboursement et vous n'y avait pas de
de principe de précaution disons pour
votre société
alors le fait tous des prévisions de
trésorerie on suit ça au jour le jour
j'avais des confrères par ailleurs chef
d'entreprise qui osent poser aussi des
fois des questions ils ont mon bain par
sécurité
je vais aller prendre un prêt garanti
par l'état elle a parlé moi je le redis
je leur ai répondu très simplement que
moi j étais tout simplement opposé si je
n'en ai pas besoin
je ne vois pas pourquoi je prendrais un
prêt garanti par l'état sous prétexte ou
peut-être par sécurité si dans le futur
j'ai un problème
ça me permettra de simplifier la vie je
pars du principe que on fait un emprunt
dont on a besoin
fait appel à un pg quelqu'un de monsieur
qui dirigeait le restaurant la fontaine
et qui était pas notre cas et qui est
heureusement je dirais on chanceux de ce
côté là ce n'est pas encore notre cas a
toujours pas si on reprend l'exemple de
la fontaine on l'a compris à un secteur
de la restauration qui a été fortement
touchée par cette crise épidémique est
devenue une crise
économique on imagine donc la nécessité
vous l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure
d'avoir recours à ce tg concrètement ça
vous a servi à quoi ce pe
alors le pg a servi surtout à faire face
aux frais fixes monter deux mesures qui
ont été prises tout sic par le
gouvernement les deux étaient
excellentes à mon avis la toute première
ça a été le chômage partiel évidemment
donc les salariés ont été mises à l'abri
tout de suite ça a été fait
immédiatement
la deuxième c'était le pge et le pg e
permet nous a permis de faire face aux
frais fixes de l'établissement qui se
situe entre 12 et 15 mille euros par
mois quand même donc on aurait pu
peut-être faire face un petit peu
quelques mois avec ça sans savoir ce qui
allait se passer dans les trois ou
quatre ou cinq mois ce2 qui arrivait
donc personne aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on nous sommes en 2021
il ya huit ou neuf fois de sa personne
n'imagine est aujourd'hui dans une
situation comme ça donc mon collègue
chef d'entreprise qui n'a pas eu besoin
du ps je sais bien c'est parfait
tant mieux j'espère pour lui que sa
trésorerie va pas en souffrir qui aura
pas des événements nouveaux qui vont
nous empêcher de travailler et que sa
situation ne va pas se dégrader parce
que c'est des choses qui peuvent aller
vite qu'ils le soient aussi bien comment
il semble que jeu et on va vous faire
réagir dans un instant nickel croître
yeux ça vous a permis quand même d'avoir
une vision sur l'avenir tout de même une
petite vision sur l'avenir son sens pge
c'était plus difficile bien sûr
évidemment c'est pas vraiment une vision
sur l'avenir c'est à dire qu'il ya une
continuité dans l'établissement tout
simplement michael croit en dieu vous
souhaitiez réagir à ce que l'on vient
d'entendre
on imagine comprenait aussi la situation
par exemple des restaurateurs qui ont dû
avoir recours à ces jeux complètement
c'est à dire que nous on a pu continuer
de travailler ce qui est pas été le cas
de la restauration et malheureusement
c'est pour ça je comprends tout à fait
la situation difficile dans laquelle il
comprend la nécessité du pg pour eux
nous on a eu la chance de pouvoir
continuer de travailler continue à
enregistrer des commandes et à fabriquer
et à les expédier c'est en cela que
on n'a pas eu de problème de trésorerie
parce qu'on a continué à à vendre et
donc aussi à acheter à nos fournisseurs
et tant que les projections trésorerie
qu'on fait au fur et à mesure les
voyants ne sont pas alors anjou rouge
et bien c'est pour ça qu'on n'a pas fait
de p g même si on a enregistré une
baisse significative de notre chiffre
d'affaires
nicolas d'envoyer pour une dernière
question michel coiteux rue quand on
voit que bercy a décidé de prolonger
du coup la possibilité de demander un pg
au 30 juin 2021 en fonction de
l'évolution de la conjoncture économique
par rapport à votre activité est ce que
vous pourriez 1 envisagé de prendre un
pg e d'ici au 30 juin
je ne l'exclurais pas mais je regarderai
vraiment très près parce que le but du
jeu c'est pas dans trois ans si j'ai
juste si si j'ai 99 % de chances ne peut
pas en avoir besoin c'est pas pour les
impulsions restant que j'irai
naturellement
merci d'avoir été avec nous par
visioconférence michael croit en dieu je
rappelle que vous êtes le dirigeant de
la société automation en 2000 pme de
serre variés qui est basée à coignières
et merci à krikor dinars yankee a été
avec mon plateau dirigeants du
restaurant la fontaine qui est à
montigny le bretonneux et on le rappelle
spécialisée dans les
dans les produits de la mer voilà merci
d'avoir été avec nous vous comptez vous
cette salariée je n'ai pas précisé à
montigny-le-bretonneux et merci
également à nicolas landry de la
rédaction de tv 78 à partir de demain le
sénat examine en deuxième lecture le
projet de loi bioéthique adopté à
l'assemblée nationale en août dernier ce
texte permettra notamment l'ouverture de
la pm à la procréation médicalement
assistée pour toutes les femmes à cette
occasion vous le voyez sur ces images
plusieurs associations dont la manif
pour tous réunis sous la bannière de
marche aux enfants manifestaient dans
une soixantaine de villes en france vous
voyez les images à versailles
mobilisation dans la cité royale sur la
place d'armes pour un millier de
personnes selon les autorités huit mille
selon les organisateurs
ces manifestants demandent le retrait du
projet de loi il dénonce je cite une
marchandisation du corps humain et des
manipulations génétiques les débats
seront ouverts durant trois jours au
sénat
à partir de demain mardi au chapitre
politique la visite d'audrey pulvar dans
les yvelines la semaine dernière elle
avait annoncé sa candidature pour rappel
pour les élections régionales l'ancien
journaliste conduira la liste
ile-de-france en commun soutenue par le
ps le prg et places publiques
retour sur ce déplacement avec astrid
bergère et célia gars tsongo pour son
premier déplacement dans les yvelines en
tant que candidate aux élections
régionales
audrey pulvar a échangé avec des
syndicalistes cfdt de l'usiné renault de
flins à l'horizon 2024 plus aucun
véhicule ne devrait y être construit une
décision difficile à comprendre pour la
candidate
renault est un groupe qui a reçu des
aides de l'état y compris dans cette
région y compris pour le pour le site de
flins est que cette aide n'est jamais
été conditionné que les aides de la
région n'ait jamais été conditionné non
seulement à des principes des
obligations environnementales mais aussi
sociale ça semble inimaginable
aujourd'hui les salariés de renault
flins produisent la zoé et la micra de
nissan avec l'arrêt de ses productions
il ne resterait sur l' usine que des
activités annexes
il y a un savoir-faire à flins depuis
des années c'est fabriquer des véhicules
on a su faire et même trois véhicules
différents des électriques et thermiques
même des amériques de partenaires on
était la première usine à fabriquer avec
électrique pour le groupe et toute cette
expérience cette expertise on peut pas
accepter qu'à disparaissent demain c'est
qu'ils craignent c'est l'impact sur
l'emploi et sur le tissu économique
local
on sait qu'à un emploi direct dans
l'usiné de flins génère 10 emplois
directs dans la région donc on pense que
il y aurait 40 mille familles impactées
directement par l'arrêt de la
fabrication
et ça aussi c'est pas tolérable pour nos
enfants pour l'avenir et pour les
commerçants
et voilà et pour tous les jeunes aussi
de la région notre combat va dans ce
sens mme audrey pulvar soutient donc les
salariés de l'usiné dans leur combat de
son côté la direction avait présenté fin
2020 aux représentants syndicaux son
projet de reconversion dans le
reconditionnement automobile on ouvre à
présent dans ce journal à un nouveau 7,8
dossier un dossier de la rédaction qui
est consacré cette semaine avec des
yvelinois c'est une rencontre qui vous
est proposé avec des yvelinois qui ont
grandi dans les quartiers dits
prioritaires et qui ont réussi et qui
s'engagent désormais dans leur commune
c'est le cas notamment d'ahmed bauchi
car originaire de là derrière ils
assurent la protection rapprochée de
personnalités en parallèle il est devenu
médiateur social pour la municipalité
son portrait par nicolas landry il a
assuré la protection rapprochée de la
chanteuse taylor swift ou du basketteur
américain de nba kobe bryant garde du
corps de profession ahmed bouche icare a
débuté dans les métiers de la sécurité à
l'âge de 18 ans il s'oriente ensuite
vers la protection rapprochée en passant
plusieurs certifications à l'étranger ce
qui lui a permis d'assurer la protection
de plusieurs stars on va faire du bouche
à oreille beaucoup du bouche à oreille
comment appeler parce que j'avais un bon
profil parce que j'ai été formé aux
états unis en angleterre et au canada
aussi en france donc il m'a permis
d'avoir ce week-end carte pour l'honneur
fait pour ce jour-là ahmed est venu
s'entraîner au parc sportif philippe
cousteau de la verrière endurance
agilité musculation l'objectif est de
maintenir une condition physique
quand un gars du corsa pas évident quand
on a des obstacles donc il faut toujours
se préparer pour ça donc c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui j'anticipe tout le temps
à m'entraîner tout le temps dans le
gymnase fait vraiment aussi un risque
moi tu es toi le kevlar
et en même temps son enfance ahmed la
passer à la verrière il a notamment joué
au sein du club de football de la
commune
comme un signe du destin il occupait le
poste de gardien de but ça m'a beaucoup
apporté
surtout avec deux personnes qui étaient
autour de moi qui m'ont beaucoup
conseillé
après tout dépend du domaine document
beaucoup conseillé sur sur leur vie quoi
en plus de sa profession ahmed toufiq a
fait partie de l'équipe du week-end des
médiateurs sociaux de la verrière un
engagement pour sa commune son rôle
échanger et discuter avec les jeunes des
trois quartiers de la ville pour
développer le lien social
l'important c'est déjà de faire le lien
avec tout le monde en fait entre les
jeunes les jeunes et moins jeunes entre
la police et les jeunes dans ces deux
fois dans la vie c'est pas facile mais
voilà on peut toujours s'en sortir avec
les bonnes personnes et on peut être
toujours donc conseillé même si des fois
dans des familles certain temps à le
faire où chaque personne comme des
jeunes sont mal orientés donc un nous on
est là pour ça pour les aider les
orientaux pour ahmed la médiation est
complémentaire avec sa profession dans
le contexte de la crise sanitaire
difficile de trouver de l'activité dans
la protection rapprochée
le verrier roy espère des jours
meilleurs avec en perspective la coupe
du monde de rugby en france en 2023 et
les jeux olympiques de paris en 2024
et puis pour refermer ce journal le zoo
de thoiry propose de vous lever tôt pour
découvrir un parcours de lanternes à
partir de 7h30 une ballade dont le parc
baigné de ferries est proposé aux
visiteurs sediag à tsonga et mickaël
millero un spectacle féerique c'est ce
que propose le zoo de thoiry
avec son parcours d'un kilomètre 5 de
lanternes non décompte des animaux des
animaux fantastiques des animaux
domestiques des animaux du zoo la bise
en fun
la lumière n'est pas que la ligne aile
et les bruitages les sous c'est
l'ensemble quand on se balade on est
dans un pays d'éléments pour les viets
après on s'est levé à 5h45 lundi branche
produits galicie puisque normalement le
parcours touahri lumière sauvage se
déroule le soir alors couvre-feu oblige
le zoo ouvre de 7h30 à 9h30 le matin on
inverse la journée c'est à dire que 7h30
9h30 on voit le lever du soleil cette
fois est pas le coucher du soleil avec
toute la féerie et la magie qu'on peut
trouver le matin avec de la bombe et ses
magnifiques également une autre
expérience et la brume ce matin là était
bien au rendez vous et ce ne sont pas
les horaires matinaux qui ont arrêté les
visiteurs une super 5 avec lui mais bon
ça me gêne pas pour faire des bonnes
choses comme ça ça vaut la peine
ça fait quand même presque un an qu'on
fait plus rien du tout et le taux de
qu'ils aient
quand même réussi à ouvrir et à garder
au moins ça une petite respiration un
petit peu dans tout seul dans toute
cette vie un petit peu morose l'éveil de
thoiry devrait se poursuivre ces
prochains week-ends en attendant le
lancement d hébergement de thoiry au
printemps une expérience nocturne au
sein de la réserve des sources
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité dans un instant ne
manquez pas le 7-8 sports présenté par
nikki haley demi d'euros il reviendra
notamment sur la troisième place au
vendée globe a obtenu par le skipper des
yvelines louis burton du football
également à suivre avec la qualification
au 7e tour de la coupe de france à des
yvelinois de confiance est à suivre
quant à nous on se retrouve demain pour
une nouvelle édition du journal très
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]